We want to figure out what the sum of all of the numbers that are entered is.
And also what the count is. So, we can use them to calculate the average and
return it. We can use a do loop to collect the user input. Somewhere in the do
loop we'll have to update value by getting the next user input. So, we'll need
to ask the user for a double, and then read in the next double using the
scanner. If the value is 0, then we want to quit, but if it's not, we want to
increment count and add to the sum. So, count goes up, and sum goes up. So, how
long do we want to keep going? We want to keep going as long as value is not 0.
Because if value is 0, that means we read a 0 from the user. So, we continue
doing these steps, as long as value is not 0. Let's try this, after I fix up my
syntax errors. Running the main method. If I enter 2, it doesn't quit. Negative
3, it doesn't quit. 0, it stops. And it gives me an average. Let's look at the
program again though. There's some repetition here. We have to check that the
value is not equal to 0 in two different places. We could change this so
instead of using a do while loop it would just use a while loop and only check
the value as not equal to 0 in one place. We would declare a Boolean to track
whether we're done or not yet. Initially, we're not done. So, it starts as
false. Then, as long as we're not done, we would keep doing the things in the
loop. So, we wouldn't need the while at the bottom. As is, this loop would go
forever because we never change the value of done. So, when do we want to say
that we're done? Well, we want to say that we're done if somebody puts in a 0.
So, if the value is 0, then we set done to true. This will work the same way.
When I run the main method, it'll ask for doubles until I enter 0, and then
give the average. You can structure any loop and a half this way using a
Boolean to guard your condition.